diese gerichte wären normalerweise im
müll gelandet aber in der küche des
kopenhagener restaurant schrubben stubb
kommt das auf den teller was bauern oder
supermärkte sonst weggeworfen hätten
sören grimms drückt der koch friert
reste 1 macht gemüse haltbar und
verarbeitet obst zu chutney um nichts
verkommen zu lassen
ihr einkommen sind
diesen nicht schlecht also die sind nur
übrig geblieben im system weil wir die
verbraucher nicht kaufen wollen
das restaurant befindet sich in einem
kulturzentrum in der altstadt kopenhagen
das fast 300 jahre alte gebäude ist
eines der ältesten der stadt mehr als
100 freiwillige arbeiten hier verzichten
auf einen lohn sowie elisabeth der dpa
ich habe oft das gefühl dass die leute
viel reden das ist ein schönes gefühl
auch mal wirklich etwas tun zu können
frisch eingetroffen
typisch dänische spargel kartoffeln die
einfach zu groß sind und deshalb vom
bauern nicht verkauft werden können
40 prozent der lebensmittel sind spenden
der rest wird dazu gekauft
sören grinst rumpf kreiert daraus
täglich spontan ein neues menü machen
weil ich habe hier über überschuss
salfer das hauptgericht heute muscheln
mit pommes
normalerweise würde man ein gericht
machen und dann müsse man die unbedingt
diese sache haben
diese zutaten wir haben vielleicht eine
idee ein haupt den greens kartoffeln
mussten
und da müssen wir es dann müssen wir es
zusammen machen obwohl wir einige in
grenzen so gingen einige zutaten nicht
dazu haben das müssen wir auch
austauschen 2013 gründet eine gruppe von
freunden das restaurant startkapital nur
1200 euro ihr ziel etwas gegen die
nahrungsmittel verschwendung unternehmen
denn ein drittel des weltweit
produzierten essens wird weggeworfen so
viel los ist eine der mitbegründerinnen
einige von uns haben als wir jünger
waren in küchen gearbeitet und gesehen
wie viel essen weggeworfen wird
also haben wir uns zusammengetan und
überlegt wie man dieses ganze essen
sammeln und weiter verwenden könnte
bevor es im müll landet inzwischen
melden sich viele verkäufer die ware
übrig haben
heute bringt ein café besitzer frische
kaffeebohnen für die er keine verwendung
mehr hat sogar selbst vorbei ich mache
das für den guten zweck und für ein
gutes karma
andere restaurants greifen die idee des
ruppen stop auf wie das im sommer
eröffnete instock in amsterdam
es gibt weltweit schon viele cafés und
cateringunternehmen die aussortierte zu
appetitlichen verwandeln
abends herrscht in rotenburg hochbetrieb
vorspeise brot nachos eine erfindung des
hauses wegen des vielen geschenken
brotes alternativ focaccia mit
petersilien pesto die hauptgerichte sind
vergleichsweise günstig der andrang im
roggen stop ist groß zu den besuchern
zählen politiker touristen und studenten
es war sehr gut auch wenn ich jetzt zu
viel gegessen habe fühlt sich das gut an
weil ich weiß dass ich lebensmittel
gerettet habe die portionen sind mit
absicht klein damit nichts im mülleimer
landet nachschlag gibt es dafür gratis
wir sagen uns immer wenn wir dieses
restaurant schließen müssen weil es kein
überschüssiges essen mehr gibt dann war
es ein erfolg danach sieht es man muss
wohl sagen leider momentan nicht aus bis
sie ihr ziel erreicht haben wird es hier
weiterhin gutes essen geben für einen
guten zweck denn die einnahmen werden
gespendet